>>> A DIVISION I VOLLEYBALL
MATCH AT BRIGHAM YOUNG
UNIVERSITY TURNED UGLY.
IN A LETTER POSTED ON TWITTER,
RACHEL RICHARDSON, A START OTHER
DUKE'S VOLLEYBALL TEAM WROTE
THIS, MY FELLOW AFRICAN AMERICAN
TEAMMATES AND I WERE TARGETED
AND RACIALLY HECKLED THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRETY OF THE MATCH.
THE SLURS AND COMMENTS GREW INTO
THREATS, WHICH CAUSED US TO FEEL
UNSAFE.
BOTH THE OFFICIALS AND BYU
COACHING STAFF WERE MADE AWARE
OF THE INCIDENT DURING THE GAME
BUT FAILED TO TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO STOP THE UNACCEPTABLE
BEHAVIOR AND CREATE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
AS A RESULT, MY TEAMMATES AND I
HAD TO STRUGGLE JUST TO GET
THROUGH THE REST OF THE GAME.
BYU OFFICIALS HAVE ISSUED AN
APOLOGY AND BANNED THAT ONE
PARTICULAR SPECTATOR THEY
IDENTIFIED FROM ATTENDING EVENTS
AT ANY OF ITS VENUES.
JOINING ME IS MARVIN RICHARDSON,
THE FATHER OF DUKE UNIVERSITY
VOLLEYBALL ATHLETE RACHEL
RICHARDSON.
MARVIN, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US.
I'M SO SORRY FOR WHAT YOUR
DAUGHTER HAS HAD TO ENDURE HERE.
TELL US ABOUT THIS.
YOU WERE WATCHING THIS MATCH ON
TELEVISION, HAD NO IDEA WHAT WAS
GOING ON UNTIL RACHEL CALLED
YOU.
WHAT DID SHE TELL YOU?
>> NO, AS YOU INDICATED, WE WERE
WATCHING THE MATCH AT OUR HOME
HERE IN MARYLAND.
DURING THE GAME, HAD NO CLUE
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
AND THEN AFTER THE GAME, YOU
KNOW, WE ALWAYS TALK.
AND SHE CALLED, BUT THIS WAS A
DIFFERENT CALL, RIGHT.
SO SHE WAS CRYING, SHE WAS
UPSET, AND RACHEL'S NOT THE
PERSON THAT CALLS AND CRIES OVER
A LOSS.
THAT'S JUST NOT WHO SHE IS.
SHE'S BEEN PLAYING THE GAME FOR
A LONG TIME, SO WE KNEW
SOMETHING WAS WRONG.
AS SHE STARTED TO TELL US WHAT
WAS GOING ON AND WHAT HAD
HAPPENED DURING THE GAME,
NEEDLESS TO SAY, FIRST, YOU
KNOW, ANGER, OUTRAGE, AND THEN,
YOU KNOW, JUST A REAL NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT SOMETHING WAS
DONE TO CORRECT THAT WERE THE
THINGS THAT KIND OF CAME ACROSS
US.
>> SHE WAS STARTING FOR THIS
PARTICULAR MATCH.
>> CORRECT.
>> THE SOLE AFRICAN AMERICAN
PLAYER WHO WAS --
>> ON THE FLOOR.
>> -- ON THE FLOOR AT THAT TIME.
THERE ARE A FEW OTHER BLACK
PLAYERS ON THE TEAM AS WELL THAT
WERE ENDURING THIS.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
DID SHE TELL YOU WHAT WAS
HAPPENING?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, RACHEL'S VERY
STRONG, VERY MENTALLY TOUGH, BUT
SHE'S 19 YEARS OLD ALSO.
I THINK DURING THAT TIME, YOU
KNOW, THE ONE THING THAT AS A
COMPETITOR, YOU KNOW, SHE JUST
DIDN'T WANT THIS TO TAKE HER
AWAY FROM HER GAME, TO TAKE HER
OUT OF HER GAME.
SO, SHE HEARING THIS, YOU KNOW,
PLAYED THROUGH IT AND REALLY HAD
TO JUST KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
STRUGGLE TO FOCUS ON THE GAME,
YOU KNOW, AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT -- WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THAT DOES TO AN
ATHLETE AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PERFORM AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES, IT'S
JUST NOT RIGHT, ESPECIALLY NOT
IN THAT KIND OF A COLLEGE ARENA.
>> SHE LETS HER COACHES KNOW SO
THE OTHER PLAYERS -- THEY
ALERTED THE COACHES AND THEY
TRIED TO TAKE ACTION.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SO, THEY MADE IT KNOWN WHAT
WAS HAPPENING.
AND AT THE POINT IN BETWEEN
GAMES, THE TWO DIFFERENT SETS
WHEN IT HAPPENED BETWEEN THE
SECOND AND THE FOURTH SETS,
THAT'S WHEN THEY'RE AT THE -- AT
THE COURT.
AT SOME POINT THEY MOVED A
POLICE OFFICER DOWN TO THE
STUDENTS' END OF THE COURT.
YOU KNOW, PERHAPS THAT'S THE --
THAT'S AN ACTION, BUT IS THAT
THE ONLY ACTION THAT SHOULD BE
TAKEN?
I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN AT SPORTING
EVENTS.
WE'VE BEEN IN VOLLEYBALL FOR
FOUR YEARS.
I HAVE FOUR DAUGHTERS THAT PLAY
THE GAME, THREE AT THE COLLEGE
LEVEL.
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD THAT OCCASIONAL
IDIOT THAT'S JUST THERE IN THE
CROWD, RIGHT, BUT NEVER -- NEVER
AN ATMOSPHERE LIKE THIS WHERE
SHE SAID THAT